it's going to be cal cuatro who is
having a nice year he has really stepped
up in the starting rotation uh coming
off a loss against the red sox so he's
going to be looking to see if we can
stop this three-game streak the twins
have on the indians right now
eighth pitch of the advent
swing and a miss quattro strikes him out
to start the game
sends this one sky high to shallow right
field and comes mercado they needed one
line and that's out number two
swung out a broken band flare into
center field caught by the shortstop
rosario and cal cuantro cruises through
the first
andrew albers had a real hiccup down in
tampa throws the stats
it
off quite a bit
a little breaking ball
weak ground ball and a rise throw straw
out one away
fly ball into center field gordon
twisting back to his left he's there
and now he's walked ramirez and reyes
and here's harold ramirez
blocked by rorvette
and
now they got the runner hung up between
second and third and that might be the
end of the inning and is
hitting fifth tonight playing first base
no score second inning first pitch he's
swinging a blast to left field down the
line deep in the corner back it goes
deep it goes that ball is gone a home
run miguel cenoa's homeward and
back-to-back games now 26 on the season
and the twins take a one-nothing lead
on the first pitch sinker that ran back
down and inside cino did not miss it
375 feet
hit ball to second miller with a great
pitch to rosario who turns the double
play
[Applause]
there's a lighter in the right field you
change stays hot coming into third and
stopping his big hero
kepler has a great arm and got off a
really good throw
1-1 pitch tap weekly that's going to be
a fair ball played by albers the runner
at third has to hold as he throws out
miller indians now with runners and
second and third and catcher austin
hedges to the plate
and got him with a fastball and there is
potentially an awfully big strikeout two
down
oscar mercado looking for that huge two
out rbi hit
2-1 pitch line drive left side speared
by donaldson to his feet throws him out
to one hop smash and donaldson save two
runs
and runs the indian scoreless inning
streak to 25 in a row
that's to right field
and kepler to the line making the catch
one away and that'll bring up jose
ramirez
and sono makes a catch right by the step
here is fran mill reyes walked his first
time up fred meal drives one deep center
field back is gordon he's looking up
goodbye
and goodbye scoring drought after 25
innings brad mill can smile and take a
jog around the faces the indians have a
2-1 lead on his 28th home run of the
year
see how easy it is
pops it up
back goes jose ramirez
easy play
one now
ground ball to third jose goes to second
there's one on to first inning ending
double play
the start of the year didn't revolve
around him he delivers a slow breaking
ball and gets a strikeout looks like we
might see that one here
trying to hit the outside corner with it
another breaking ball to hopper to
donaldson
two and two
and came up and in for a
swinging strike three in a clean one two
three inning for lucero
high fly ball right field
mercado
makes the catch
polanco lofts this one into shallow left
ramirez in and the indians left fielders
there and polanco out number two
ground ball right at amid rosario
takes his time throws them out twins go
one two three
cal cuatro cruising right along 3-1
cleveland
fastball bounced to donaldson
high throw and cenote kept the foot on
the bag ceno's been pretty good over
there footwork wise at first base
there's been some things that he hasn't
gotten exactly right but he's been
pretty good that way
slowly hits simmons scoops
flips two away and a pitch 202 ground
ball right side arrives to his left
comes up throwing in the dirt picked out
by snow
camp
has made
78 pitches through six innings one
mistake miguel ceno hit a solo homer to
left
swing and a miss struck him out right
now austin the hedges is
discussing something with miguel cino
and i don't think it's on the
friendliest of terms here comes cal
quantro to home plate and cal cuantro is
being told no no
but
and now quantrill staring him down the
whole way to first base and sono looking
back at him
and now the umpires are getting involved
here he had something to say to sono
ceno
is at the coaches box on the first base
side he's turning and being ushered into
the dugout by the first base coach
[Applause]
seven strong innings of work tonight
rooker ring them up
cal quantrill seven strong innings of
work tonight jose ramirez zoe for two
couple of pop-ups in a walk he'll swing
it left-handed for the first time
tonight
he's trying to go back it's deep
kepler's on a room it's out of here
fulby wants shame on you fool me twice
shame on me yeah are you kidding me you
just saw what he did to that pitch on
the inside before he came right back in
and jose got him another home run the
third of the night for the indians for
ramirez that's going to be number 33.
cal cuatro pitching into the eighth
inning
five straight starts he's gone at least
six
the pitch waved at gordon strikes out
and 3-2 pitch
in the air left field harold broke in
now he's got a race back he's there
makes the grab
two down
two down and max kepler taps it on the
right side rosario with the throw bucket